pour les victimes de violences sexuelles
comme Mélanie Lemée dénoncé et toujours
un acte courageux qu'elle puisse
s'exprimer dans ses propres termes sur
son processus et le message de sport
qu'elle essaie d'envoyer aussi plus
largement la société moi je pense que
c'est très important
parce que je crois que toutes les agents
doivent être dénoncées avec son
documentaire la mairesse de Longueuil
veut démystifier le processus judiciaire
je leur ai fait avant mais
protéger les gens là dedans les prises
de parole de personnalité publique
peuvent avoir une incidence sur les
dénonciations et même les plaintes à la
police selon cette experte c'est vrai
que ça encourage éventuellement d'autres
personnes qui ont aussi été victimes de
différents mauvais traitements ou de
violence à prendre la parole par la
suite si je reprends le code Nathalie
Simard c'est que bon dans les mois qui
ont suivi ça dénonciation publique il y
a eu une augmentation significative du
nombre de signalements aujourd'hui j'ai
une belle voile je suis très fière de
l'avoir fait et depuis cette sortie en
2005 il y a eu plusieurs vagues de
dénonciation dont Mitou plusieurs cas
ont été médiatisés et ont contribué à
miner la confiance de certaines victimes
envers le système de justice les
dernières années ce que fait les
nouvelles c'est des dossiers où il y
avait pas d'accusation ou des
accouchements qui sont aussi ça suscite
la grogne ça suscite la méfiance mais
des changements aussi étaient opérés il
y a quand même des efforts continuent le
tribunal spécialisé en est un effort
continu parce que là on veut mieux
encadrer les victimes on veut les aider
dans leur témoignages à partir du 1er
témoignage qu'elles font lorsqu'elles
vont faire le signalement au poste de
police Catherine Fournier a d'ailleurs
insisté sur la qualité de
l'accompagnement qui a reçu tout au long
de son cheminement
harolden a été reconnu coupable
d'agression sexuelle un verdict qui peut
aussi donner espoir à certaines victimes
même si chacun est unique des
expériences positives des fois sont pas
toujours tributaires du résultat on
envoie des personnes victimes où il y a
pas d'accusation dans leur dossier où il
y a un accouchement qu'ils ont tellement
été bien accompagnés que sont nés en
moins fiers d'elle la justice criminelle
lorsqu'elle fonctionne bien
offre une résolution du problème que ce
soit par un acquittement ou une
condamnation c'est qu'il y a une fin un
moment donné pour Catherine Fournier la
fin c'est de reprendre le contrôle de
son histoire ici Jacques Audrey
Charbonneau Radio-Canada Montréal